[Música]
era el último acuerdo nuclear vigente
entre Moscú y Washington y la semana
pasada por el aniversario de la guerra
en Ucrania el presidente Vladimir Putin
decidió suspender la participación de su
país reviviendo La retórica de amenazas
nucleares cuando las relaciones con
occidente son extremadamente tensas por
otro lado la renegociación del acuerdo
nuclear de cinco potencias con Irán
sigue estancada y Corea del Norte que
busca consolidarse como una potencia
nuclear con este escenario analizamos
Qué significan las movidas en la carrera
armamentística conectamos para ello con
Fernando cocho quien es analista de
inteligencia y riesgos a la seguridad
nacional Fernando Un saludo para usted
Gracias por estar en directo a América y
llama la atención que Putin dejó Claro
que no abandonará el New Stars sino que
sólo suspendía su participación Cuál es
la diferencia Y además ya se preveía que
Rusia podría salir de este marco en
algunos años
Buenas tardes Ángela desde aquí un
placer estar con vosotros Pues sí Parece
ser que al final no solo sea contra se
ha hecho una contraofensiva por parte de
Rusia diciendo que va a abandonar ese
tratado de aromentístico sino que se
echa los brazos de China de Irán Y de
cualquier otro Aliado que pueda
encontrar en Asia que pueda comprar sus
armas generando por tanto una nueva
llamémosle así guerra fría pero en este
caso mucho más peligrosa puesto que
estamos hablando de energía nuclear o
avances en energía nuclear en misiles
intercontinentales por tanto veremos lo
que ocurre pero nada lo que va a ocurrir
como ya dijo blinken les afecta desde el
punto de vista geopolítico en Ucrania o
Rusia si no les afecta desde el punto de
vista de sus intereses en el Pacífico
concretamente con Taiwán y con el
crecimiento
sostenido de dos puntos dígitos de paro
por parte de China
Estados Unidos dijo este lunes que la
decisión rusa demuestra que no son un
poder nuclear confiable y el kremlin por
su parte ha dicho que no ve opciones
para un final Pacífico en la Guerra de
Ucrania para ustedes razonable pensar
que podría darse una intervención
nuclear desatada por esta guerra
bueno primero hay que pensar que ambos
generan sus propias narrativas no
dedicadas a su público o a sus
colaboradores o a sus aliados yo Espero
que no haya una guerra nuclear
de ninguna manera porque significaría lo
que se llama destrucción masiva
asegurada o destrucción total asegurada
puesto que Rusia a pesar de que se
considere que es una potencia que no ha
cumplido el ranking de ser segunda
potencia mundial artístico por sus
estrategias obsoletas militares pero sí
sigue teniendo 4.000 y pico 5000 cabezas
nucleares en perfecto uso por tanto
Aunque falle Y aunque sea anticuado
puede generar muchísimo daño esa
capacidad nuclear que sí tiene Rusia
aunque no sea la suficiente como para
oponerse a la otan Pero bueno tampoco
quedarían muy parados muy en parados ni
Europa básicamente y el resto del mundo
no Y además el costo que tendría que
utilizar este tipo de armamento y de
aquí quiero pasar a otro tema y es que
Irán no ha llegado a un acuerdo
finalmente con las cinco que incluyen
también Estados Unidos para el bloqueo
de su carrera nuclear Cómo se ha
fortalecido en estos años Irán
nuclearmente desde que Donald Trump
abandonó el pacto que había sido
negociado por su antecesor Barack Obama
pues
enriquecido o sea ha aumentado su
capacidad romántica no solo por una
capacidad propia de diseños propios
intentando lograr la independencia
militar sino también por los alianzas
que tiene de manera directa tanto con
Rusia como en China Por tanto la
tecnología de estos tres países Rusia
china e Irán puede ser tecnología
compartida de doble uso incluso y por
ello Irán Bueno no es nuestra potencia
desdeñar uno un país como Estados Unidos
tiene 33 bases militares rodeando a Irán
Y eso solo puede significar que lo ve
como una amenaza real patente y
humildemente importante en la región El
problema es que Irán tiene una manera de
pensar muy diferente como los eslavos
también a lo que es la parte occidental
la parte democrática nos seguimos
olvidando de la manera de pensar que
tienen tanto los iraníes que es una
teocracia islámica como Rusia que es una
visión nacionalista Ultra ortodoxa y
seguimos pensando a la occidental no
pensamos como piensan ellos y por tanto
podemos llegar en una a un acuerdo no
llegamos a un acuerdo satisfactorio
desde el punto de vista de Europa claro
y entonces pensando en eso se logrará
eventualmente un equilibrio en el
acuerdo con Irán Por qué occidente en
términos prácticos no logra desatascar
el acuerdo ya llevamos varios años en
esta negociación Y a qué costo
bueno no se sabe no se Desactiva no se
pone en marcha otra vez porque no le
interesa a Estados Unidos básicamente
Europa no es independiente
geopolíticamente ni militarmente ni
estratégicamente ni energéticamente y lo
es dependiente por tanto de Estados
Unidos y al no interesarle
geopolíticamente Estados Unidos pues
Europa una vez más se convierte en
Brasil segunda fila o servidor los
intereses geopolíticos
de Estados Unidos sino de que a nosotros
nos afectaría un ataque a la frontera
rusa o de qué forma sino Ucrania hubiera
entrado en guerra y no es por los
conflictos por los intereses políticos
de Estados Unidos independientemente de
que Putin es un tirano y es una persona
que debería ser procesada por lesa
humanidad Pero eso no justifica tampoco
las acciones de manera directa
y Fernando La amenaza atómica también
viene de Corea del Norte Kim Jong ha
declarado que quiere consolidar al país
comunista como una potencia nuclear en
medio de las tensiones su vecino del sur
y con Estados Unidos pyongyang dijo que
podría considerar incluso una
declaración de guerra por futuras
maniobras que se desarrollan entre seúl
y Washington qué tan cerca estamos de
que esto se concrete
bueno el caso del Norte es diferente
Corea del Norte utiliza las armas
nucleares la civilización nuclear La
amenaza nuclear para que se rebajen las
tensiones y las sanciones económicas y
para que otros países como china por
ejemplo pueda facilitar acceso alimentos
acceso medicinas acceso intercambio de
combustible por tipo de elementos y así
sobrevivir el régimen de Peón no es no
lo veo una amenaza real y tangible
puesto que Corea del Norte no tiene la
capacidad Aunque tiene capacidad nuclear
no tiene la capacidad de amenazar
geopolíticamente ni a Corea del Sur ni a
Estados Unidos que protege a Corea del
Sur actualmente es digamos una un
Brindis al sol para intentar conseguir
mejores beneficios económicos y sin
embargo no se sabe Mucho realmente a
ciencia cierta de lo que Corea del Norte
puede o no puede hacer Cuál es la
información que se tiene acerca de la
carrera nuclear en ese país Comunista
Pues todo lo que sabemos de coral en el
norte hay que tocarlo con con pinzas
porque es un régimen extremadamente
errado y hermético y lo que podemos
saber es que sí tiene carrera nuclear
suficiente a Costa de la hambruna de su
país a Costa de hacer el pigmento en
otros servicios básicos como sanidad
educación o la reindustrialización del
área agropecuaria no pero sí lo que
sabemos es que intenta convertirse en
una potencia nuclear disuasiva para
conseguir mayor beneficio económico pero
a Costa de su población Y eso tarde o
temprano le pasa la factura al al país y
tarde temprano veremos si no una
hambruna como la que ya vimos hace unos
ocho años
enyang que murieron casi dos millones y
medio de personas o será algo parecido
Pues bien muchas gracias Fernando cocho
analista de inteligencia y riesgos a la
seguridad nacional gracias por su
análisis y que tenga un feliz día Muchas
gracias Un placer estar con vosotros a
nuestros televidentes se sigan con
nosotros ya volvemos con más de directo
a América
[Música]